night of the beating details emerge of
riyadh ritz carlton purge but this is
kind of interesting it is yeah three
years on some of the saudi detainees
reveal what they say took place
in early november 2017 nearly 400 of
saudi arabia's most powerful people
among them princes tycoons ministers and
shakira were rounded up and detained in
the ritz-carlton hotel in what became
the biggest and most contentious purge
in the modern kingdom's history the
arrest shook the foundations of saudi
society in an instant turning
untouchable establishment figures into
targets for arrest statuses were
discarded assets seized and business
empires upended a conventional pact
between the state and its influential
elite was shredded overnight now leading
figures uh caught up in the detentions
have revealed details of what they say
took place
many of whom were stripped of fortunes
portray a scene of torture and coercion
and of royal court advisers leading
chaotic attempts to understand the
investments behind the wealth of the
king wouldn't it be great so imagine our
version of this
and it's just swedish house mafia you're
playing their music and the torturers
are going how is this we don't
understand how you make this much money
we don't get it
some of it is okay but most of it i
don't know
we don't get it
because that's what happened here the
the saudi officials are going how do you
doing this how are you making all this
money
like they could they could bring ringo
starring and just you know put him up on
the rack and go
you were the least talented beatle like
by far
i don't understand
george wasn't great either but
the disclosures come in the third
anniversary of the purge and ahead of
the g20 summit in riyadh
this week and advocates
uh
of the right to woman to drive among
them but see that's what's cool saudi
arabia they know how to balance it
they'll do something like this then they
go let the women drive
look a woman's driving
wait you just tortured everybody she's
making a left look at her make a left
and everyone goes ah
she is making a left so what they did
and we don't need to go into every
detail here because you can get it and
you can read the order okay hold on i
like this yeah on the first night
everyone was blindfolded and nearly
everyone was subjected to what egyptian
intelligence calls the night of the
beating
i mean
what if biden just came out and said
this
like he said in response to the pandora
papers we kidnap
a swedish house mafia and we subjected
to them what we would call and you know
biden says it very calmly because uh
they call them the night of the beating
people were asked if they knew why they
were here no one did they were beaten
many of them beaten badly they were tied
to walls stressed positions and went on
for hours and all the doing the
torturing were american good old usa
so the interrogators arrived on the next
day so the first day is the beatings of
the torture and the next day the
interrogators
the detainees had by then but separated
into rooms in the hotel that a year
earlier had been the venue for the
launch of prison muhammad's ambitious
vision 2030 here's the thing with mbs i
i feel like i like him
yeah yeah he's great
well
there's people who have said negative
things but
he's never done anything to me i live in
beverly hills and i'll say this i like
him
i think he's great
and i am not in any way
criticizing the saudi royal family they
have indoor lakes and they ride jet skis
on them
and i don't even care about 911 i don't
like finance people that much anyway
there is a misconception that they
turned up all knowing with pages of data
and information they didn't they
the interrogators knew very little and
they were winging it
they were hopeless on the offshore stuff
so basically this is what
you have two options yeah when your
pandora papers come in
and obviously there's a third option
that involves like congress passing laws
you know but you know but you katie
porter is ferocious but you'd have to
have a bunch of katy porters you know
katie porter can only do so much she's
she's trying to do her best and make a
grilled cheese for everybody
um so what you could do is you could
lock everybody up in a hotel and beat
them and torture them or you can just
kind of do what we've done which is
write real estate blogs about the houses
they bought
and go stunning modern chic
it's a stunning modern chic beachfront
complex that was not going on in riyadh
they were not talking about the stunning
modern chic complexes it was the night
of the beating
this is
this is these are the choices you can
have night of the beating yeah
night of the beating
or real estate blog stunning modern
sheik
many of the king's neighbors were they
were they were in a tizzy they didn't
know who lived there
um
many of those who came in
i'll tell you this man it's difficult to
know what to do
isn't it
it's hard
because mbs is sitting there and saudi
arabia does horrible things to
all kinds of people
um
but he's sitting there and he finds out
not to me
yet
and he's sitting there and he finds out
that people are
they're they're they're taking money
they're stealing they're doing kind of
what's written about in the pandora
papers that's right and
he goes
we're gonna have to have
a little bit of a talk
and we're gonna have to lock everybody
up in the ritz
and the party's over
and my my thing is if katie porter
god if katie porter yeah
kidnapped
jamie diamond in a minivan
[Laughter]
like in a lunch lady outfit yeah
like dressed like chris farley from
lunch ladyland if she threw jamie
diamond in a minivan
with a bunch of other ceos and took them
to like the four seasons
okay
and
just directed their torture
i don't know that you'd
get anything out of it but
the pure aesthetic value of that to me
is not nothing
you know what i mean you'd be like oh
dude they mean business they're not
kidding around
there was a terrible shake-up in america
the elites were on the run
lunch lady and congresswoman
katie porter and i know she's like a
lawyer but she looks like a lunch lady
she does lunch lady katie porter
in the middle of making sloppy joes
kidnapped
jamie dimon
and a bunch of other ceos and brought
them to the four seasons hotel where
they were mercilessly tortured by
interrogators
and she's just sitting there she's like
where's the money
mr diamond
i feel like we've met before and he's
like what there's a chain on a wall
she's like we've met before haven't we i
believe i asked you a question about how
people at your bank could make ends meet
i broke down all their monthly expenses
what and the guy's just hitting them
yeah i remember
well mr chairman i have a few more
questions for you do you have the time i
think you do
he's just chained up in a suite
at the four seasons hotel being
brutalized by interrogators and then
katie porter is like all right so mr
diamond
let's let's just
let's start by saying i'm your friend
and i think we both want the best for
america wouldn't you agree jamie and
he's like please stop this i'll give you
anything you want well i'm glad you said
that
because i have a lot of questions about
your bank
about
about your lending practices
about the money that you've paid to get
out of serious government inquiries so
i'm glad you're here and just
just lashing this kind of and again i'm
not saying it's the right thing to do
i'm just saying these seem to be the
choices these are we live in a world of
so few choices there's not much to do
when these things come out
so you either
drag all these people to a hotel and
beat and torture them or you just kind
of ignore it and you go bad boy
you're a naughty boy
you're a naughty buy are you being a
naughty boy in martha's vineyard i bet
you are there's not you know